okay let's now talk about a little bit
about dr. Anthony Fauci months ago the
Trump administration made it clear as I
just told you a few minutes ago they're
moving past coronavirus they're done
with coronavirus at least from the
standpoint of talking publicly about the
virus and the pandemic we saw the press
briefings essentially eliminated when
Donald Trump wondered aloud about
injecting bleach and isopropyl alcohol
putting them into the body as he says to
treat coronavirus the press briefings
stopped a couple of weeks ago we heard
from dr. Anthony Fauci that he was
speaking to Donald Trump less and less
frequently and this week in an interview
two days ago doctor foul she confirmed
he has not spoken to Donald Trump at all
in more than two weeks
remember dr. Anthony foul he is the
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Disease he's
essentially the top infectious disease
doctor in the country he has made it
very clear over the last week that
states that aren't ready to reopen
really shouldn't reopen he has made it
clear that if states open and businesses
don't stick to the guidelines that are
established it's going to go really
badly doctor foul she said a few days
ago very specifically he would not go to
donald trump's tulsa oklahoma rally this
saturday that's a bad idea he wouldn't
go to any other events like it either
and now he has confirmed that the last
time he spoke to donald trump is more
than two weeks ago and even then trump
only wanted to know about what was going
on with vaccines and this is because we
know trump is increasingly obsessed with
vaccines not for health reasons but
because he believes that a vaccine is
something he could take credit for to
justify his re-election in November the
last time Trump and foul Chi spoke they
didn't talk about coronavirus exploding
in many states they didn't talk about
cases hospitalizations resurgence spread
it was just what's going on with the
vaccine because Donald Trump thinks
that's something he could use to get
himself reelected so this is not an
accident my friends from the standpoint
of the political position of the Trump
administration the corona virus pandemic
is over and
now what's that it's the the return to
greatness or what RiRi oh I forget what
the stupid propaganda term Trump came up
with is something about greatness
that's what Trump sees right now and
Trump even said this week you don't do
any more testing you won't find any more
cases problem solved right haven't you
taken a look at the stock market
everything's great now just stop testing
and then we won't have any cases how
many Americans are going to die because
Donald Trump never took this seriously
and then stopped taking it seriously
after only taking it seriously for a
very short period of time how many
Americans are going to die because
Donald Trump by even having a huge rally
is implicitly signaling to his
supporters you can gather in large
groups go ahead listen I'm having 10,000
people at my rally you can go ahead and
have 20 people over no big deal and of
course then the spread will continue the
president has not even spoken to the top
infectious disease doctor in two weeks
and more Americans have now died of
coronavirus than the number that died in
World War one there's all sorts of
different metrics and statistics that
have been put together comparing the
death toll to all sorts of other
horrible horrible things so Trump is
trying to make coronavirus go away by
ignoring it it's you know we could have
that object permanence conversation
again about little kids unfortunately
and this is the the real tragedy he's
convinced tens of millions of Americans
to do the exact same thing we I've been
speaking to friends in Florida friends
in Arizona
people are just mostly acting like
everything's fine yeah you still have
some people wearing masks and staying
home but the virus doesn't need that
many people to gather to continue
spreading more and more quickly six US
states are seeing record highs in cases
twenty US states are seeing increases
the six big culprits are Florida Texas
Arizona Oklahoma Oregon and Nevada in
terms of percentage growth and they have
had their highest single day spikes in
the last week now in some cities within
these states things are so bad that bars
have started to close even though
they're allowed to be open so there's a
place in Jackson
Florida Lynch's pub so many of their
employees and customers got coronavirus
that even though they're allowed to be
open according to the Florida guidelines
that are currently in place they said we
have to close because this is absolutely
crazy so we are now in the please
disperse move along nothing to see here
phase of the pandemic except much like
in the Leslie Nielsen movie Naked Gun
explosions are going on in the
background while they say move along
nothing to see here
step back nothing has been resolved the
broken healthcare system hasn't been
fixed the underlying economic fragility
of our system has not been addressed we
are not any better prepared for the next
outbreak we still aren't testing enough
we have no plan to prevent a second wave
if we even get a break between waves one
and two
literally nothing has been fixed
although fortunately some states and
we're gonna hear about one state in a
moment some states are doing enough to
modestly keep things under control